okay welcome again for this second talk
i am run with a speaker and the talk is
about happiness insight associa a job
social network analysis sorry okay
welcome everybody to happiness inside
the job social network analysis you may
be wondering why there is two speakers
listed here well a bad news Jose is not
able to be here today so I will be the
one talking I am
young-ran I am a telecommunications
engineer and by data module cognizer and
i'm looking for the job so if you want
to follow us on twitter and talk with me
we can do it that later
well this talk will be about how to
analyze social day or network data from
a mobile phone application in order to
predict employee turnover as an
indication as an indicator of employee
happiness we will explain how to use
machine learning and network analysis
techniques to build a model that allows
to rank employees by the risk of
quitting the job this measure is
important because an employee who quit
can represent an expensive problem and
also shown risk can be used as a great
KPI for a human resources department so
let's stop talking about the source of
our data or not yes well for two years
happy force has been helping companies
with an app that they deploy to
understand the workforce better without
it meant to be used by the employees to
provide feedback to both their company
and their peers from an employee
perspective there are three main
features that an employee can use first
they can vote daily based on the
happiness level they can also give
feedback as Animus comments that can be
read by other employees from the same
company those comments will be posted on
a company forum where the employees can
anonymously like or dislike other peer
comments this talk will cover some of
the aspects that have to be taken into
account when build
at some risk model such as what kind of
information we have available how our
data set looks like how we can use graph
theory to gain insight on our data set
how to build machine learning models to
predict an splain embody Turing and
finally we all have to look at the code
that was used to perform this analysis
here we can see the amount of data that
has been collected during the last two
years it one corresponding to each one
of the app teachers this data is stored
in four different CSV files each one
containing different types of
information we've touched planing the
Vote CSV file where it is contained the
information regarding the votes and
employee issued it not only contains the
numeric value of the boat but also the
date in which the word was issued so it
also contains two other columns that are
common to all the CSV files that allow
us to uniquely identify an employee the
first one employee contains an index
identifying the employee entire company
and company alias is a string
representing each one of the companies
that the employees belong well have a
seat
regarding comments information the
community else has been anonymize while
maintaining its original number of
characters it is also available the
information about about when the comment
was posted and the number of likes and
dislikes that it received there is also
CSV file containing the information
about likes or dislikes that they give
an employee gave to a comment it is
possible to know if an employee liked or
disliked a comment but we have no timing
information available of when that
happened finally we have one more CSV
file that we will use to boot to build
ours as a variable that contains whether
an employee is still sign up or not in
the app and the last interaction that
that employee had with yet it also
contains how many volts it was issue but
we like to calculate it using the first
CSV so you know these two columns are
the one that will be used to build a
hotel just very well the first one I
still this will be used home will be
used to check if the employee turn and
the last interaction day will be used to
monitor if there has been a delay
between the employee using the app and
the human resources department
notification the company that has the
other example max my happy force so we
have information regarding votes
comments interactions and whether an
employee quit the resort or not and this
information is stored in four different
CSV files and containing information
about 34 companies and more than 400
4000 employees now that we are we're not
now that we are aware of the structure
of the data let's see how it looks like
this chart shows the count of votes
issued daily group by companies
most of the votes were very should do
the business business days and this is
the reason why we can see some small
dips corresponding to weekends it also
shows the growing trend both in the
number of companies that sign a PDF and
in the number of votes that were issued
regarding both information this is the
most information representing the answer
to the question how happy are you award
today and the dancer represents a
numerical value ranging from one to four
notes that it is no neutral answer and
therefore people tend to choose three
over two to account for neutral
happiness it turns out that it's easy to
say have good than when how whatever
this means have no names so maybe it is
because people tend to be confused about
the meaning of the two unhappy ones I
don't know and this way the chart shows
the average simply happiness on a given
week play this reprise here is that
Tuesday not Monday is the least happy
days however as we all know and we all
hate mondays the biggest drop in
happiness it is from Sunday to morning
to Monday
public wisdom says that you should never
save the job interview on a Monday not a
Friday well the same is true when
posting a comment this way the chart
shows the number of light that a comment
received depending on the day of the
week that it was posted on average a
comment received 7.5 lights however the
day the comment is posted has a great
influence on the number of likes that it
will receive a comment posted on Monday
will receive an average 1.5 likes less
than one written on fire on Sunday so
Monday and Fridays are the worst day to
post did you want to be like to improve
with our sport or data analysis we will
blow the timeline for the turn
information that we Stratus from the
last CSB
this figure it is possible to see the
timeline describe describing the number
of employees that quit
goodbye companies it's possible to
notice at least three wheel spins that
could interfere with our machine
learning models the first one is this
peak here of employee turning on June 14
and knowable it turning until mouthpiece
15 and when they start to turn we can
see that the young we belong to one
company furthermore we have one day in
which whole company turned this is maybe
they sign off the album
instead of closing the company I don't
know but this means that if we have
wheels in here we will need to do some
data cleaning so do not forget to
visually do not forget to visualize
their data mainly to get a sense of
what's going on so this way it's easier
to spot trends and imbalances in the
data set and do not forget to evaluate
weekly and seasonal sets because they
must they can be significant
visualization is usually one of the big
ways to look at that o as we see in some
inconsistencies in the data set we will
use graph theory to build an ultimate
representation of our model I of the
data set this way it will be easier to
see what is really going on with the
data discuss representation will be
useful for two things first assess the
data integrity of our data set and see
how the employees interact with each
other this is select features that
describes how the employee behaves when
posting comments and liking each other
as you already know a graph is a
mathematical object comprised of
vertices or nodes and edges but there
are several ways to choose what kind of
information they will represent in our
graph nodes represent employees an edges
will represent information about how to
employees interacted with each other we
can define the relationship in different
ways it means that we can use different
rules to indicate one a net will be
drawn between two nodes for example one
of the most simple yet effective
representations is the undirected graph
interactions where the weight of each
vertex is proportional to the number of
lights plus dislikes that to employ you
get each other in example the connection
of the direction either direction of the
connection is not relevant it will be
relevant if we choose to represent our
data as a directed graph this means that
an employee a liking B is not the same
as employee be like a they can also be
assigned different ways to the edges for
example instead of the number of
interactions that occurred between two
peers we can use the likability that we
describe as the percentage of lights
among all the interactions that two
employees change in order to represent
in order to represent differently our
graphic presentation for the record from
now on we will call the lights divided
by likes what he likes
likability let's see it will be a
quantity that will be talking from the
wall there are many possibilities when
building a graph representation another
one could be instead of looking at
whether employee a commented with B to
add an edge between two nodes is both
like the same comment here we could use
any metric that we want to create this
representation but we
from now on we'll still with you are
directed like grasses and directions the
following plot we have used ball K to
represent the undirected graph of
interactions but also we have used the
line marker properties to highlight
additional information from our data set
when representing each note we have used
the size and color properties of the
blood to display information about our
datum when the second its node that
represents an employee its collar tag or
its likability ranging from blue blue to
represent employees that were hated by
their peers to red to represent
employees with high likability therefore
the most popular ones all the nodes that
are transparent mean that they have no
information available about people who
voted
yeah this is the rift yeah we have
looking at the day at the real world
data set this is a company that sits and
has lend us the data to make this
presentation and the likability as we
said is defined as the proportion of
likes it changed between between two
employees for example if I give you ten
lights and twenty dislikes your
likability will be one in the third they
are given anonymously on the company
forum where the comments are positive it
simply can like or dislike any comment
they want you can also like your own
comments silly there is a very high
proportion of people who only like their
own comments and we have used color
information and we also have used the
site information to represent the min
boat score of the employees bigger nodes
represent happy employees while the
small ones represent employees with a
lower global world votes you can see
that there are notes that representing
us dots
this has note that we don't have
information about it could be that
because they didn't vote or because they
turn and well partially deleted from the
database using this representation it is
well under edges here we can see how the
likeability distributed in a company
they are color according to its
likeability ranging from red to indicate
haters why this one here to green to
indicate a high proportion of lights it
change between two employees using this
representation it is easy to see that a
lot of information is missing if we did
people we will discover what I said
before that our missing information
belongs mostly to employees that turn
and will partially the lady from the
database so they should
be used if we want to have a consistent
machine learning model it means that
some data cleaning is required if we
want to avoid misleading our classifier
we will we will start by defining an
arbitrary prediction date will choose
one date and an observation period
during which we will try to predict if
an employee Whichard we will only model
employees that use the app at least five
votes who interacted with their peers at
least five times and who will active
after the prediction date we will remove
all the empathy children before the
petition date so we don't have all the
missing data that we have before when
this filtering process is done you can
see how two companies look like here we
have used the same coloring team for the
edges as the one used in the previous
slides but in this case we have colored
each note according to its own
information certain employees are the
ones covered in red while the other ones
did not turn and here we can see how the
whole dataset looks like we have
modified the size of the notes and the
color to make the term employees big and
red so they are easier to spot and in
this case we have colored all the
vertices according to the number of
interactions between two users blue
means that those two users that are
linked by net will have interaction less
than the ones colored in red so if you
want to use with a theory to model your
data first be careful to you to choose
between directed and the rate of
representations both are valid but they
will be representing difference in
different types of information
it's also valid when applied to wait
because waste can help you describe
different aspects and interrelations of
your data that are not really easy to
support if you only use the table of
representation and do not forget to use
additional line of marker properties to
display more information you want when
plotting the network's course once we
screen our data define our prediction
date and define our salvation period it
is time to create the features that we
will use in our predictive model using
data only from the remaining employees
that was collected before a prediction
date we will extract features belonging
to four different categories first we
have employed individual features such
as statistics and a number of votes
likes or dislikes and the number of
interactions that a given users have
with his peers we can also calculate the
same features as a company level it was
first used in a paper presented at
national conference last year in link
linked linked in job search algorithm
these features are the same as the
employee individual features but at the
company level and they will be shared
across all the employees that belong to
the same company and then we have also
the employee company features that are
the employee dividual features divided
by its company mean this is a way to
relate how an employee behaves in
relation to to their peers in the
company and finally we will have social
features that are the ones that we
extract using network theory
one of the last one of these graph
features is is obtained using
non-negative matrix factorization or nmf
that is a clustering technique applied
to the adjacency matrix of the graph
here we can see how a gas-free the
feature extracted using n MF is
distributing you put n MF could be
thought as a kind of principal component
analysis but applied to the to the
adjacency matrix of the graph you will
choose the number of components when
applied in this n MF technique that each
one will represent one of the clusters
in we would like to divide our graph it
will like to the gas for example if we
like to divide our graph into clusters
we could make n MF of two components
here it is represented the first
component of the n MF on D and directed
graph interactions the first one we
explained and the one we are using
through the whole to the whole
presentation and here I use using a
color map that you are familiar with
ranging from blue to low values to red
for the high ones the resulting
component of the LMF are continuous
values these values indicate how much
that nodes belong to a cluster but
sometimes it is useful to discretize
those values into bins this way it's a
bit easier to see what each one of the
clusters you're representing as this is
a feature that is not is interpretable
sometimes it comes in handy as you see
here to represent this values bins into
into n into n colors in this case we
have used blue for the wall values red
for the neutral ones and orange to
indicate the values that balanc most to
the first component cluster
to model or data we have chosen the
gradient boosting classifier trained
with default parameters this may see
this is not really performance model but
we want it to be able to interpret and
that information in order to understand
better what churn is more than half a
high-performance core if you have
questions about how to improve these
models we can talk about it later
once this model is created we'll take a
look at what features are more relevant
oh yeah well which features do you think
are more good well you already know so I
have spoiled myself let us paint away
these features we all know what
likeability is have explained it a
couple times
posting frequency is a company features
means it is shared by all the camp all
the employees from the same company and
it's the number of posts per day Britany
the company we also have relative
happiness and relative variability of
happiness that are too relative features
extracted from the mean of the votes and
the standard deviation of the bolts it
means that we we got the employee
information and normalize it by it by
the information of their peers in the
same company we also have the nmf first
component and finally the mean happiness
of the employee now you can see the
relative influence of the different
features and it's interesting to take a
look at the type of features of the
feature that we have it turns out that
the most relevant feature is the only
features that do not depend directly out
of on what an employee does with the app
as plain likeability only depends on the
ratio of lights to this life that you
are given but the only way to influence
the lives of these lies you get is
changing the way you post but you cannot
interact directly with the a pin of the
two tails this variable also the four
subsequent features the second one is a
company feature that it that don't
depend directly on the employee unless
he was the only one voting or he bought
it really far more than the others and
the two relative features depend also on
how the employee behaves with respect to
its peers to his peers we also have one
social one social feature static for the
LMS component that you have visual ID
for and finally we have the mean
happiness of the employee which is the
only individual feature in which which
can be extracted directly from the from
the employee information so you can see
here the likability likability density
density plot separating users who turned
from users who don't here you can see
that likeable employees turned three
five times less and most of the
employees that have the hassle really
roll like likability ratio end up
turning while employees that churn and
have high high likes to of ratio high
likability
we're very were less than the employees
who don't who didn't churn sorry
so before going to see how the code to
make this loads and presentation looks
like we I would like to remark three
three ideas that you should go home with
when one listen to the discipline sorry
well to sum up please when trying to
match of happiness use finds not query
the end the employees asking what they
think as you saw many employees are
happy and very few will tell you that I
am unhappy or me I'm not ok with my job
but if you look at facts it is this job
turnover you can get more realistic
representation of what's going on in
your company in try to measure happiness
not by service I said before bus at some
risk and know that it not depends on
what an employee does it is not an
inside job mostly the the fact that you
will end up quitting your job or not
depends mostly on your colleagues on how
you relate to them of course it and
learning for employees filled disengage
with system with their company these are
things that what this all makes sense as
we all hate mondays
we don't will we tend to feel happier on
weekends weekends and we really value
our college treat us in work so hello so
del personnel please give me one second
but well I think I will stop talking
about this and I start the questions and
answer round so I stopped making a mess
of myself and we'll take a look at the
code that was used to perform this this
presentation so please help me a bit
my English is awful I don't like talking
so if you ask me questions
I can I can be oh sorry
[Music]
please any questions because this had
just trash and thank you first of all
don't worry I mean it's normal and and
then the second thing is I encourage to
know if you also look to correlational
of the features for example people that
is popular so popular people is also
happy for example of things like that
because a Jew it's interesting that
they're likely that I mean the the the
the number of like or dislike is that
being you on and discriminate the
clusters but I was thinking that for
example if you also look to to the real
like the connection the like the clique
for example if you look to the cliques
you qu you should and so you can see if
if there are connections subgraph that
are complete maybe these also telling is
something out the people is really and
they they show for maybe the same
property for example all the people in
the same clique are all happy in the
same way for example something yeah we
have I have explained the non-negative
matrix factorization as one example of
features that you can extract using
graph theory but if you take a look at
the notebooks there are many features
that we that we calculated such as
centrality matrix please we have also
yeah
we have distant relatives we have used
what the moment have my backup slide
be plan so we do like graph theory you
come with me and we'll discuss it later
we have here animations different types
of features that can be a strategy using
graph theory each one can be used to
perform on a specific type of analysis
and they can be compared with the
feature started using the traditional
machine learning techniques the one
thing that I would remark that you have
to be careful when combining both graph
and non graph features because they
sometimes represent the same information
and if we use both you are only adding
nodes to your model instead of improving
it after five minutes if you have any
other question it's okay if not I can
show you how I did those plots using a
builder dashboard to use those floats
those plots it is through the 2d plot
made using bulk air actually you won't
be able to see he recalled the
resolution is not really well but it is
all online on the repository of this
talk and this is mainly a dashboard that
takes as input a network X graph and
allows you to fine-tune all the market
online properties that Bokke plots have
so you can choose how you want them to
be represented for example here I will
map the size of the graph of the of the
notes to the mean happiness of the
employee so when I update this blow this
plot
you can see how all the different those
changes so we want to use to this tool
to to analyze your features it comes in
handy because you are able to represent
information in the ways that tend to be
difficult you don't have this kind of
dashboard you know some of if any of you
are interested in how this works now we
can talk once this presidential is
finished well thank you very much but I
can any other questions thank you
everyone
[Applause]
can you please just post a link to the
presentation again yeah actually I have
it here
here you have my github and the
repository this is on please is some of
the speaker is here we have to make an
agreement for the net by data because I
have like 40 50 positive support that
are called by database am 2017 well
another question here in the beginning
you you show us that this data is a bit
biased or like support and which kind of
techniques did you apply to to deal with
this yes there are libraries such in to
learn or I don't know how it said that
have different techniques that allows
you to deal with some by unbalanced data
if we can now talk about it if you want
I can show you in the notebooks there is
a pipeline using balancing techniques in
order to improve a bit the the
performance of the machine learning
models well it's been a pleasure being
here and thank you very much
[Applause]